so first of all as you will appreciate
this is a live investigation
it's almost unprecedented for a police
force to talk so openly about the
circumstances of an ongoing case in
which they're about to interview the
only suspect but almost everything about
the death of Harry Dunne and a collision
between his motorbike and a car is
highly unusual a White House meeting
between his parents and President Trump
followed by a statement in Parliament
from the Foreign Secretary about the
issue of diplomatic immunity and now a
request from answer coulis the woman who
fled Britain for the police to come to
America to interview her she wants to
meet officers and she wants to express
all the condolences that so she has
already done but she also wants to
expressly the devastation that it's
caused both here in the UK and here in
the States and her family but she
doesn't want to return to Britain where
her husband worked at an American base a
job she used to claim diplomatic
immunity Harry's parents who were back
in Westminster to meet the shadow
foreign secretary Emily Thornbury are
upset that the police failed to tell
them that mrs. sakulos had left the
country this is the kind of dig English
I promised the family I'm going to do I
will work with them I will do everything
I can to try to get to the bottom of
this we smell a rat and and we need to
find out what really happened
the Chief Constable denies he's under
political pressure we will not bow to
pressure we have never bowed to pressure
the Foreign and Commonwealth Office will
not dictate and did not dictate the way
that this investigation would run and
nor will it mr. utterly says the delay
in telling the family about mrs. sakulos
departure was partly because it
coincided with Harry's funeral and he's
warned their official spokesman against
making potentially prejudicial comments
I'm well aware of my responsibilities to
not jeopardize a fair trial
but but let's let's be honest if I
hadn't put my arm around this family and
come and worked with all you guys to
reach out to the public that mountain
would not have been moved encircle is's
new police interview will be added to a
file already sent to the Crown
Prosecution Service the police are well
aware that a successful extradition
request is probably the only way this
case proceeds to court that will be a
matter for lawyer
and maybe for governments in woods
skynews Northamptonshire